can you imag you're in the Skull and
Bones tomb and these
idiots start talking
about you
know the fact that uh they they're
they're they're mad that Angela Basset
didn't win the I mean Jesus Christ is
anything can't people just be evil
anymore can't you just be why do we have
to get adjusted to a new kind of evil
all the time can't we just know what
evil is and regard it when we see it and
know how to avoid it or mitigate its
effects what is evil why is it so good
at morphing all the time all these
sociopathic personality types constantly
are are rebranding themselves so it's
very hard to know evil
is it's amazing it's like you think you
would just get used to one type evil now
it's like you know it you know it keeps
morphing and changing